non è come tua madre deve crepare di
cetrioli infilati nell'ano periodo
natalizio
ciao ciao o kido eco occhi dolci occhi
dolci sorriso smagliante con la gioia di
vivere questo video sono fa riferimento
ci siamo su un altro gioco di mera sto
scherzando se non gioco figo ve lo giuro
si chiama ddos knight e tre ce ne
sarebbe un'altra dicono è morta di
phinet freddi sì quello schifo di
seriamente l'ho scelto perché sembra
figo username ma serio ma come banana 48
di sugo la nonna giusto si è perfetta
che funziona ma ricordano le mie
password force knight ragazzi prima è
già partito più figo di phinet predica
la madonna è così e così figo non ha
veramente così fino allora rightmove
button flashlight perfetto lim in lim
out
e dov'è lì non c'è tutto il senso di sta
roba però ha così
ok bellissimo qualcuno mi spiega che
cosa dovrei facili mi devo girare
intorno mi devo girare intorno va bene
lì non sa è una donna
quante corsie si sono il soggiorno
abbiamo impossibile soccorre ma se
inserito cazzo il più bello di far
niente freddy's davvero presse z l'altra
invece porta è questa qui ok quindi se
se vedo qualcuno che passa basta che
chiuso se cosa giusta ricapitolando devo
controllare l'impatto di roba ciao
ragazzi ho finalmente posso vedere dove
sta la gente
salve fratello è la senti nomi fare
scherzi e per cortesia tra l'altro
ragazzi sono le 5 di notte se mi manca
un'ora ho vinto e non ho fatto un cazzo
ho vinto ho vinto fa chi è a secco onda
il ragazzo re alla prima notte è stata
difficile non è successo un pene ma sono
in quattro rega c'è anche un tipo dietro
a carissimo
ma questo va chi inizia è questo qua
spunta a caso c'è una quelli sono in
cinque soccorrere ma pieni di ragazzi
c'è qualcuno che ha riso ma non ho
capito chi va beh
giri perfetto mi mette in ansia che non
avete idea a stò gioca perché le tendine
erano aperte chi è che ha aperto le
tendine del bagno pervertiti schifosi
ragazzo ai tutor a me si gira male
subito briga briga ragazzi sono andati
via in due ragazzi sono andati via in
due non li vedo già più che restavano
due qui dove cazzo sofia e come qua
bello 6 l'altro saremo in tre
minchia el'altro chi è che ha aperto le
tendine del bagno perché le devo tenere
chiuse le tenere nel bagno che si si
aprono lo succede qualcosa di brutto
fantastico è andata di culo non ho fatto
in tempo a chiudere temine nel bagno
dove l'altro ragazzi
che tu voglia ladra bastarda
[ __ ] figlio tanto rock io mi sono
caricato troppo messo o cacato zucchi a
milano quella di prima il bello è che
dalle telecamere non si vedeva niente
non sa dove cazzo è uscito non si è
capito va bene a venire si fa tenere
alto lo scherzo così vivi stupro la
norma che sta aprendo le tende con
questa lentezza incredibile come lo
spiega giorno bella giornata è al questi
rumori magari non lo dico perché sono
una persona amichevole fatevi i cazzi
vostri non mi rubate in corridoio per
cortesia dai che so le 5 di mattina
forza dovremmo avercela fatta se sei
terza notte o che da adesso in avanti
torno inizierei problemi perché in un
file nei del freddy's non ho mai finito
la terza notte mai
vabbè che cazzo non c'è nessuno dove
come siete ragazzi ocala uno fa qualche
bello che ora guarda quanto successo
che cazzo è successo a passo dovreste
saperlo ormai tutto non ho capito che mi
è spuntato uno a caso sono già tutti
sono chaplin nessuno fantastico ma sono
partiti a un minuto da e rega minchia
rai zio borja mia serio questa non la
sapevo di poter nascondere sotto la
scrivania ma serio ci sono un miliardo e
mezzo di cose da fare visto gioco non è
come tua madre deve crepare di cetrioli
infilati nella non periodo natalizio
vada pure il mouse scassato ormai
fantastica o tremori il cugino ragazzine
di fare l'ultimo tentativo per che sta
uscendo la roba esageratissimo di tutte
ste morti che ho fatto ragazzi che lo
giuro non tra vita neanche una è
spuntato un porco la è che sarebbe
questo qui dietro porca [ __ ] la tenda
la tendina mi son dimenticato la tendina
e dimenticarsi la tenda kesicki di apre
che finisco male
ha passato dall'essere proprio facile
all'essere impossibile veramente da
questa dal terzo in poi niente da dalt
abete da questa data per cantare il
bello è che all'inizio mi sembra
talmente facile che volevo aumentare
anche la difficoltà ma alcun caso
proprio chiusi porca [ __ ] si è chiuso
aperto aperto sono un deficiente di
merda ho aperto la porta come un
[ __ ] ho aperto perché avevo chiuso e
poi offerto avevo chiuso già a
prescindere cioè la modalità difficile
c'è la modalità questa la modalità
normale normale ai ragazzi sono un
deficiente che è stata saggia si sapeva
quindi non è un problema esiste anche la
versione hard che questa la versione
normale la prossima volta la faccio
perché sono masochista
quindi ragazzi spero che rino mi sia
piaciuto concludo che episodio un bel mi
piace perché ho trovato ho scoperto che
l'acqua in situazioni drastiche funziona
appassionato assumo filippino che che mi
tiene la bottiglia così quando prendo un
infarto mela versa in automatico con che
ragazzi concluso che l'episodio spero
che visto che sia piaciuto a cosa è
servito per questo momento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e con i
video totale iscrizione sono sistemici
diavolo costruito bello ragazzi